En el siguiente sistema de ecuaciones,
"x" más "2y" igual a 13,
"3x" menos "y" igual a -11,
¿el punto (-1, 7) este punto
que tenemos aquí
es solución del sistema?
y bueno,
si este punto es solución del sistema,
eso quiere decir que cuando "x" vale -1...
lo voy a poner así...
"x" vale -1,
entonces "y" debe de valer 7
y se tienen que cumplir
ambas ecuaciones,
tanto la primera como la segunda,
se deben de cumplir
las dos ecuaciones simultáneamente,
para que sea solución del sistema.
Y bueno, pues vamos a probarlo, pero para eso
déjame poner aquí lo que estamos pidiendo,
estamos pidiendo que "x" sea igual a -1
en estas dos ecuaciones
que tengo aquí
y a su vez...
y a su vez que "y"...
que "y" sea igual a 7.
Ok, pues vamos a sustituir a "x" por -1
y a "y" por 7,
en estas dos ecuaciones,
vamos a trabajar con la primera para ver que nos
sale de sustituir estos dos valores
y qué puedo obtener.
Bueno, déjenme cambiar de color,
lo voy a hacer con color rojo...
De la primera ecuación tengo,
"x" más "2y",
ok, "x" pero "x" vale -1
entonces me va a quedar -1...
-1 más 2 veces "y"...
más 2 veces "y"
pero "y" vale 7 entonces -1...
lo voy a poner con este color...
por 2 veces 7...
por 2 veces 7,
esto dice que debe de ser igual a 13...
debe de ser igual a 13, vamos a ver
si llegamos a ese resultado.
Y bueno, aquí tengo -1...
-1 más..
más 2 por 7,
pero 2 por 7 es lo mismo que 14...
y esto debe de ser igual a 13, ok,
y bueno, si ahora sumamos -1 más 14,
esto me da 13,
es decir que 13...
13 es exactamente igual que 13
y en este caso, si se cumple,
para "x" igual a -1
y "y" igual a 7,
es decir,
para el punto (-1, 7)
podemos decir que satisface
la primera ecuación.
Ahora, ten cuidado,
satisface la primera ecuación
pero so no quiere decir que forzosamente satisfaga
la segunda ecuación, de hecho,
es justo lo que vamos a trabajar ahorita,
la segunda ecuación
para ver si también este punto
es solución de esta segunda ecuación,
pero bueno, por ahorita nos ponemos contentos
porque sí satisface la primera ecuación.
Vamos a trabajar con la segunda
y con la segunda me gusta utilizar este color...
con este color, ok.
Y dice, "3x" menos "y"
eso debe de ser igual a -11
y voy a sustituir a "x"  por -1
y a "y" por 7,
entonces me quedaría 3...
3 por "x"
pero "x" vale -1,
entonces 3 que multiplica a -1,
esto menos "y"...
esto menos...
¡Oh espera!
déjame ponerlo con el mismo color...
menos "y" pero "y" vale 7,
menos 7, esto me debe de dar exactamente
lo mismo que  -11,
esto debe de ser igual a -11, ok,
pues vamos a multiplicar.
Y dice, 3 por -1 es -3 menos 7,
esto debe de ser igual a -11, ok,
pero -3 menos 7
es lo mismo que -10...
-10, esto es lo mismo que -11
y esto no es cierto,
no se cumple esto,
cuando yo me fijo en -10 igual a -11,
eso no es cierto,
por lo tanto quiere decir
que cuando "x" vale -1...
no...
y cuando "y" vale 7,
no satisface la segunda ecuación
o dicho de otra manera,
el punto (-1, 7)
no satisface la segunda ecuación.
Y como necesitábamos que se cumplieran
las dos ecuaciones simultáneamente
para que fuera
la solución del sistema,
entonces podemos decir que este punto, el (-1, 7)
no es solución del sistema,
porque cumple la primera ecuación,
pero no cumple la segunda ecuación.
Entonces podemos responder
que no, no es solución...
no es solución del sistema,
muy bien.